regardez bien sa tête regardez bien sa
tête tu n'as pas passer par terre
[Musique]
si nous supportons que n'importe qui
fasse la police aux côtés de la police
alors nous ne sommes plus dans un état
de droit il peut pas y avoir dans notre
pays une police parallèle ou une milice
[Musique]
je
on
[Musique]
c'est vrai
à
[Musique]
ils agissaient dans le cadre de l'un de
ses jours de congé il a été démis de ses
fonctions en matière d'organisation de
la sécurité des déplacements du
président
[Musique]
m
jours de mise à pied contre qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire et
n'importe quel policier dans la même
situation aurait pris bien plus cher
emmanuel macron de ce que je comprends a
été informé personnellement
[Musique]
non non non la république m elle était
inaltérable